so let's bring in Erin preemie she is
the director of pres communications for
the Trump campaign Erin I know this
event at Mount Rushmore was not put on
by the campaign but is this perhaps a
taste of what future rallies might look
like - the fireworks of course well
president Trump is excited to be able to
go out and give what will be an iconic
address in front of Mount Rushmore he's
gonna be able to celebrate America's
history
her founding and her founders in front
of Mount Rushmore those who stood up in
the face of tyranny to establish the
greatest nation the world has ever known
honor the men and women of the United
States military who served day in and
day out to protect and bring freedom
across the world and it protected here
at home and he'll talk about the high
honor and distinction we all have as
Americans as citizens of the United
States it's gonna be a beautiful speech
at one of America's most iconic
locations Erin as you know and we just
heard our Jonathan Hunt report this
event comes with its fair share of
criticism social distancing is not going
to be enforced you have all of these
environmental concerns the threat of
wildfires and you have these Native
American groups who are planning to
protest because they're saying that this
is essentially a photo op at one of
their most sacred sites how do you
respond to that criticism well the
governor has clearly been working to
establish protocols for safety and we
encourage those who may be in a higher
risk group to be able to enjoy the
festivities safely at home as well there
are opportunities to be a part of this
both there and away when it comes to the
fireworks specifically being a National
Wildlife Service National Park Service
have been working to make sure that that
can happen safely that these fireworks
can happen safely analyst and president
Trump is going to stand in front of a
National Monument and give a speech to
our nation it will be beautiful it will
be patriotic and it will honor the
greatness of this nation all of it
let's talk about the big jobs report
yesterday president Trump clearly very
pleased with it but his opponent Joe
Biden is essentially accusing him of
spiking the football at the 50-yard line
he said on Twitter let me be clear
there's no victory to be
celebrated when we're still down nearly
15 million jobs and the pandemic is
getting worse not better
does he have a point I mean 11.1%
unemployment is still very high
despite Democrats and Joe Biden's best
effort to root against America to root
against her comeback the work President
Trump did to protect American workers
and jobs is clearly paying off we've had
almost seven and a half million jobs
created in two months 4.8 million jobs
in the month of June alone and when you
look at those numbers 2.8 million of
those jobs went to women in this country
over 350,000 went to manufacturing
there's plenty to celebrate and if Joe
Biden in the liberal elite the media the
Talking Heads who want to root against
this country because they think American
failure is their success has seen
anything about what this president has
done they know they're on the wrong path
president Trump has delivered American
greatness and he's doing it again he's
shown that his leadership will bring
this country back Joe Biden should
actually see what's happening because
there's plenty to celebrate in the
recent jobs numbers well I hope the next
jobs report is just as good as the last
one because you know that survey was
taken in the middle of the previous
month before a lot of these states had
to pause they're reopening plans so
definitely some concerning trends but
hey this job support was pretty good so
we'll take it and you can understand why
President Trump is so pleased about it
Aaron Perini thank you so much for
coming on the show and happy fourth of
July
happy fourth of July